explain to people um what
science is um
and how it's evolved over the past
decade or so
sure we began as a studio which for us
was defined originally as a holding
company so we were set up originally as
a holding company where
we would work with early stage founders
in exchange for some portion of kind of
founder grade equity typically common
shares
and we would act kind of initially as
co-founders slash investors with them
but we would have much more of an
operational role than a traditional
investor
and in the first kind of four years of
science as that holding company
you know we built businesses uh with
founders um
we started businesses from scratch and
we acquired companies and so we had this
kind of
holding company system and i think at
that point we were looking at
iac and different kind of conglomerates
and wondering whether you could create
an
early stage you know incubator studio
that would have both
earlier and later stage companies all
within a single vehicle that was the
that was the actual very very beginning
and then what worked out as you expected
it
and what didn't work i think in terms of
this model
sure so the i mean we had we had a
handful of businesses that were highly
disruptive that worked out in a really
rapid fashion
and the first one was dollar shave club
and the second one was dog
dog vacay which eventually became rover
and both of those businesses went on to
you know grow really rapidly raised a
lot of capital um
and suddenly we looked much more like a
venture fund because we had a minority
position inside these businesses
we were on the board we had some
operational influence but we looked more
like a traditional investor as they grew
some of the business that didn't work is
some of the companies we started
in-house we just couldn't get to scale
and suddenly when we looked overall at
science and the structure we realized
that this holding company structure
was really not the right structure for
early stage and
um we knew that we had to make the
progress to becoming a more traditional
venture fund
and over time that kind of got
reinforced to us
and so why is it
that the startup studio model
didn't work when you look back on it if
you were being super critical and
self-aware
what what would you say the limitations
of the model were
and then i guess how many swings at bat
how many actual companies did you or
projects did you try
because we all know 80 of startups in
the early stage go to
zero and fail so if you only did eight
or nine like maybe you didn't have
enough that you started to actually know
if it would work
yeah we tried a lot i mean so the the
port that the
the concept of taking experience
operators i mean similar to
you and i when we actually had built
businesses ourselves and putting them
around founders to get their companies
up and running quicker and to scale
quicker that worked
and that continues to work um so that
concept of a studio that provides more
than capital
um i think continues to be a highly
viable model and
greatly successful for founders i think
the concept of consolidating all that
structurally
um into a non-traditional um and to a
non-traditional entity that doesn't work
mainly because
you know startups have a long path to
liquidity they typically don't generate
a ton of profit you're obviously on this
path of fundraising
and you need to work within traditional
capital sources which which obviously
was a fund
um but over the past you know nine years
like we've tried probably over 120
different concepts so we tried a lot
and the nice part is that things that
didn't work we were able to kill really
quickly with very low capital exposure
which is a huge benefit to the model
meaning that like
you kind of figure out the things that
are going to fail early which means that
you don't have to sink
half a million dollars millions of
dollars into a concept that clearly
isn't going to work
the other positive the model is when you
test that many things you end up with
really strong pattern recognition so we
end up becoming experts in
particularly direct to consumer you know
startups so whether that's products
services marketplaces mobile you know i
think we're uniquely positioned there
because we've done so many of them and
because we're so connected to the
metrics that drive them
and the personalities of the founders
and the approaches the businesses i
think we have a better eye towards
selecting those and we know how to grow
them very effectively now
so do you maintain like a t an internal
team to build stuff to this day and
market stuff to this day
or have you deprecated that so we
maintain
a studio and a venture fund in a
side-by-side model where
um there's a studio that works with
founders that studio provides
certain skill sets to those founders
definitely on the growth marketing side
but also quite a bit on business
development and strategy and finance etc
and then we have a venture fund that
sits alongside and the goal of the
studio is to basically
t deals up for the venture fund so once
the studio works with those companies
kind of proves out the market viability
find those initial customers works with
those founders then it brings it to the
fund and then the fund begins a
systematic way of investing in those
startups
to kind of help them rise and then
eventually we go out to external funders